stephen mats has got turned things
around pat he's hit a rough patch here
lately yeah he has he's making his
eighth start this season he's going for
his sixth win
he's coming off a game where he won his
fifth game of the season that was six
days ago at houston allowed three runs
over five innings he started hot retired
the first eight batters that he faced
did not walk a batter in that game
carl strike three comes in there with
that good fastball right at the bottom
of the zone and finishes off mccutchen
one down
a little chopper tough play for matt's
he gets sided and fires a strike in time
what a nice play by the big lefty i love
how he took his time he got on that ball
very quickly and max is going to fall
off towards the third base side right
here gets on it quickly now watch how he
takes his time plants that foot and
throws a strike over to first base
there's a high fastball and he strikes
out remuto might have been upstairs but
mats will take it
and they'll face velasquez who's been
better over his last couple starts john
the zra at 4.18
his last start against atlanta was
really good
and you know i think now you you know
everyone said well you know we can get
five innings maybe six in you know now i
think it's go you know the hitters are
gonna tell you how long he's gonna be in
there
swinging a miss got him with a high
fastball
first strikeout for velasquez
[Applause]
bounces it to shorthand but shep
hustles over to third he had to avoid
that ball and took a very awkward route
to third base but he ends up safely in a
heap on top of the bag
swinging a miss
two strikeouts in the inning for
velasquez
he leaves one over third we'll go to the
second this is
herrera in the center field
little weak grounder you got to come
after it
and there's bishop in time
good inning for steven that's three of
three down no problem we'll go to the
bottom of the second shutters on first
and second with one out
and rowdy teles is coming up
and a line drive out to center field
herrera makes the catch
and they're going to double up vizio he
did not know how well he knew how hard
the ball was hit but he didn't realize
it was going to be sinking into the
glove
of oh double 8-6 on the double play
we'll head to the third
no score each team with a single hit
phillies have committed an error the
blue jays continue to play
solid defense
breaking barley repeal and it's a swing
down that first base dan is sonya the
first base umpire rings him up
that's three strikeouts now
ground ball teles broke for the bag now
he has to turn and fire what a nice play
by simeon
marcus had to wait for rowdy but he true
before rowdy actually got turned around
that was a terrific play on both ends
and he smiled about it now
you ever watch uh football when the
receiver goes down and out and the
quarterback releases the ball before he
makes his cut steven matt's trying to
pitch out of a bases loaded jam here in
the third
brown ball this should get him out of
the inning though
cool across the diamond what a job by
steven metz he strands the bases loaded
still no score chance it hitting 107
with three homers and five runs better
than
and a call strike three right down the
middle
three strikeouts for velasquez good way
to start the third and now say oscar
hernandez
tell you what there has been a ton of
traffic on the bases
swag in a missed 95.
he's gotten hernandez twice on strikes
no runs no hits two men left
steven matz we talk about his great
start he won his first four
starts as a blue jay and then in a
little bit of a rough spot coming off a
win against houston
called strike three and hoskins knew it
boy matz comes in there when he really
commits to that fastball he can lock up
some good right hand and hitters
there's another one
the phillies forgot their trigger
five strikeouts now for
steven metz
debunks beauty of a bunt matz makes a
nice play to get it but no chance to
throw him out a two-out base hit for
herrera
he's now hitting eight of nine yeah
matt's almost made a heck of a play on
that ball
if he didn't have trouble getting it out
of his glove it was going to be a close
play strike three call how about that
three strikeouts in the inning all
called strike threes on fastballs and
matt sleeves another base runner on
last of the fourth inning velasquez has
walked three
he has struck out four in this ball game
and a strike three call i'm telling you
that
they must not be able to see probably
i mean these pitches are right down the
middle
steven matz has six strikeouts through
four news
five of those have been called strike
threes
there's a good breaking ball
they get seven strikeouts for matt's
scoreless game top of the fifth first of
three against the philadelphia phillies
got him chased a pitch off the plate
outside and that ball ran down and away
from sagura
got him came back with the heater and
strikes it off
what an effort by stephen mats he
pitches out of trouble once again the
phillies leave two more base runners on
and we're still scoreless as we head to
the bottom of the fifth two down base is
clear here's the pitch to marcus simeon
swigging to miss he finally got the
change up
to go in the right spot six strikeouts
for velasquez
and a one two three fifth inning trent
thornton will take over here in the
sixth inning and thornton has been
outstanding in 11 games
should be a double play ball simeon to
the ship
academic four six three on the first
pitch on a clone hits it hard but right
to the second baseman and that erases
reese hoskins and that lead-off
single it came back with the same bits
better job by tran thornton gives up a
lead off single gets the double play in
the strikeout we'll go to the six still
no score six strikeouts for the blue
jays since velasquez has been solid
tonight 10 strikeouts for the phillies
and a breaking ball call strike three
seven strikeouts for velasquez
finch throws that breaker ball and
buckles him why not for vladi guerrero
guerrero is over one with a walk
get up this ball is going to be
gone
there's a shot to right field guerrero
continues to hit very well in this
ballpark
blondie guerrero with the first run of
the game
his ninth home run of the season rbi
number 27 and the blue jays leaded one
to nothing there's rarity spillies
threatening
faces loaded full count two outs
swing ball four a run is going to come
home and the phillies have tied this
game at one
four straight walks
that's remarkable now make them pay for
it reece reese is one for three singled
his last time up
line drive out to left center field it's
in for a base hit it's going to split
the gap and go to the warning track
this may clear the bases real mutos
heading home and he will score
a base is clearing double for reese
hoskins
fly ball right field it's pretty deep
going back on it is hernandez back to
the fence he jumped said he didn't get
it
hoskins scores easily balms to second
phillies will take it now up 5-1
hernandez is struck out twice he's also
flied to center field
and that one's lined off the end of the
bat towards second and sigour is able to
turn the double play bushette doesn't
get back
well that
is helpful
for the fills no runs no hits
one man left
let's just try to finish this one off
police trying to take game one oh two
pitch
swing gonna miss he got him
struck out three in the inning
and that seals the deal for the fills
they take game one
by a final score of five to one